good afternoon we begin with breaking
news a coroner has ruled that multiple
failures by West Midlands police
materially contributed to the murders of
a mother and her daughter in solihull
Renee muday and her mother Carla Salim
were stabbed to death by raneem's
estranged husband outside their home in
August of 2018. she'd made numerous
reports of domestic violence to the
police during and after their
relationship was guides Becky Johnson is
at Birmingham at corridor's court there
Becky what else did we learn today
this is a verdict that is very damning
of West Midlands police and their
response to multiple calls for Help by a
young mother who was being abused by her
estranged husband in the months leading
up to the murder of ranimu day and her
mother Carla Salim mizzy Day called 999
some 14 times to report incidents of
domestic abuse these included threats to
kill her these included threats to stab
her and yet repeatedly police this in
question we found did not log these
reports correctly they did not follow up
on these reports correctly they didn't
assess the risk correctly and then in
August of 2018 in the early hours of the
morning the two women were stabbed to
death by jambas Tarin the estranged
husband the woman the man that ranimu
day had kicked out after she found out
he had another wife and children in our
Afghanistan now on the night of the
murder the two women ranimi day and
Carla Salim were in a shisha bar in
Birmingham now at the time there was an
order in place that Jan bastarin should
not approach them but he was there in
the bar there was a confrontation
between them in the bar now following
that ranimu day was captured on the CCD
CCTV footage calling 999 that was the
first of four calls she made to the
police that night we can listen now to
one of those recordings
so you're not coming quickly I've been
waiting two hours now yeah because he
had left so the risk has been lowered
that's the issue but now now he's not
there he might be waiting
yeah
jobs where there are people there still
that's how it works yeah but he demands
and locked the door yeah we'll try and
see you tomorrow okay okay no he's he he
actually followed me from my mom to the
place where I was in restaurant okay but
that's what I'm saying this
[Music]
those calls became increasingly
desperate as the night went on in fact
in one of them renimo day tells police
she has a two-year-old son and she's
worried that jambasaurine is going to
get a knife and hurt them in fact in the
end it was Missy day and her mother who
was stabbed to death in a frenzied
attack an attack that was witnessed from
an upstairs window by reneem's younger
sister who was 14 years old at the time
who was babysitting that two-year-old
son who heard screams went to the window
and witnessed her mother and sister
being killed I spoke to her earlier
today and she told me of her anger at
the inaction of the police in those
weeks leading up to these murders
I think it just
hurt even more now knowing that she
actually cried for help and begged for
them and they did not come at all
and realizing in the past as well
previously from April she's been calling
and calling and nothing's been done at
all
we are now waiting for a response from
this inquest to this inquest verdict
from West Midlands police they are of
course now the latest police force to be
accused of not responding properly to
threats to violence against women the
coroner herself said that a number of
very serious concerns in the handling of
domestic abuse by this police force have
been raised and she has now ordered a
prevention of future deaths report which
she hopes will bring wholesale changes
in the way West Midlands police deals
with domestic abuse we are actually just
about to hear now from uh kaola salim's
sister ranim uday's aunt she is going to
come we believe and make some comments
live on camera I'm going to move the
microphone and we'll wait to hear from
Noah nor Norris her response to this
inquest verdict
if he's done there thank you very much
thank you
so you're mine first of all please
good evening my name is Noel Norris
my name is noon Norris
okay here today at the corona Court in
Birmingham
the truth was delivered
I wish to announce
the outcome of their verdict
the failure of the West Midland Police
has
the failure of the West Midland Police
has led to the death of our beloved
sister Raul Saleem and her daughter Rani
Moda
both were murdered at the hand of the
ex-husband of ranim of the history of
domestic abuse
coercive control and stalking all of
which police were aware of at the time
West Midland Police have failed khaola
aranim Beyond imagination they had so
many opportunity to save their lives
right up until the end both were
murdered while on the phone
to the police begging for help
on behalf of my family I would like to
to give our sincere appreciation to the
people who worked very hard
for the last four years to help our
to help us expose the truth of the
failing
also many thanks to the jury who
who went through
he went through the um the evidence for
three weeks at the time it was like
watching a horror movie
and to the coroner and her stuff
who were very supportive
we have revealed the truth but there is
so much more yet to achieve we need
changes to prevent future death through
domestic abuse we need culture change
culture change at the at all levels of
policing we ask for no more failing no
more dismissal of victims of domestic
abuse
must be to ensure that other victims
gets respect support
investigation and safeguarding that our
loved loved ones did not get
[Music]
we miss you beyond imagination
I know we can't bring you back
but may your souls now rest in peace
thank you
no what would you like to see happen now
I mean you've had you passed the
findings today what would you like to
see happen now
first of all
um after addressing the failure of
Midlands police we would like this to be
heard by everybody in order for changes
to start happening uh we appreciate we
do appreciate the
the outcome of the verdict but now we
want changes uh we want domestic abuse
to be taken much more seriously
it changes to be start to happen
immediately because there's people under
risk every day because things haven't
really changed much ever since my sister
and my niece had died four years ago we
would like police to have more
sufficient training
be more aware of the domestic abuse
policy and what goes on with domestic
abuse was cohesive controlling and and
stalking
we would like the system to be much more
stronger and efficient
and the logs to be more in harmony so
they can all log on the same log and get
the all the evidence they need instead
of having so many systems and so many
failures with the systems
are we very upset and disappointed
obviously and we have a huge emotions
that we can't express at the moment
but the only way we can actually go go
forward with this is actually see the
changes happening no do you think
I do believe so because
domestic abuse is is a raising uh
concern to everybody locally and
internationally and to fail at that
level is very concerning and not just
for domestic abuse for for any other
sectors I think